it is Thursday which means we have the
latest jobs numbers and they're not good
when we added the jobs lost in the last
week or last week I guess I would say
that puts the total number of jobs lost
during the seven weeks of what we would
I guess called the coronavirus
quarantines at thirty three and a half
million jobs last week the latest
numbers about 3.2 million more people
lost their jobs and filed for
unemployment now if you are looking at
these numbers and you are determined to
find some okay news or some sign of it's
not as bad as it could be what you could
say and you would be right to say it is
that each day I'm sorry each week fewer
people are losing their jobs we had more
than six million people lose their jobs
in the first in the last week of March
the first week of April only about half
of that number each week over the last
couple of weeks have lost their jobs in
the three million job range but in total
these are unconscionable numbers now to
give you a little bit of context before
this all started so seven weeks ago
eight weeks ago the US workforce was
believed to be about a hundred and fifty
eight million people 158 million people
were formerly in the workforce in the
United States before this all started so
when you look at thirty three and a half
million jobs that is 21 percent of the
labor force of the United States that
has lost their jobs not in a year which
would be a tragedy in seven weeks in
seven weeks if three months ago somebody
had said in the next three months one
out of five Americans who is working is
going to lose their job number one no
one would have believed it but if you
forced their hand to say how do you
think the stock market would be doing
how do you think all these if they would
say well it would be absolute complete
devastation but nobody would have
believed that that is how bad things
could possibly get in such a short
period of time but we are there now
previously before this phase before
coronavirus the largest one-week job
loss new unemployment claims
was somewhere in the 600,000 range maybe
close to 700,000 we have done five to
ten times those numbers not in total
during coronavirus each week during the
last seven weeks and again the total
number is now thirty three and a half
million jobs lost now there are people
who are seeing these numbers and they're
in the camp of open it all right now no
matter what to save the economy right
there they're in that camp and those
folks see these numbers and they say
here's the evidence here's the evidence
that we must reopen everything right now
regardless of the human cost and by the
way the human cost is really big anyway
with things shut down which is true and
that tells us just how contagious
coronaviruses that's a very
short-sighted perspective it's not a
good idea but I do believe that there
are things that we can glean from these
numbers that should inform what should
have been done and also how things
should be handled going forward first of
all even economies that appear to be
doing well Trump has called the economy
up until seven weeks ago the best
economy in the history of any country
ever I don't call it that but there's no
doubt that what we had up until seven
weeks ago was an economy that by the
normal metrics we use unemployment
inflation consumer confidence stock
market all of those measures it was
doing well it was an economy that was
doing well but what we learned is even
those economies are extremely fragile
even those economies can on the drop of
a dime make a hundred and eighty degree
turn this fragility is inherent to our
economy in part because of the marginal
nature of a lot of the work in the
economy in part because of the low
savings rate which is fueled by stagnant
wages over a long period of time
dramatic inequality also gives you
average --is that seem okay even when a
lot of individuals are in a very
precarious financial state the
just-in-time nature of many of our
industries and supply chains all of
these things should confirm to us that
even when the economy looks pretty good
by the standard metrics it's a very
fragile economy that we have that's part
of the system that's a feature of it not
a bug number two what we also need to
think about is if you look at other
countries right now if you look at Italy
France Spain a lot of these hubs of
cases South Korea of course they're all
on the dramatic decline they are doing
really really well while we are still
having 2,500 deaths a day and that leads
me to have to talk about Donald Trump's
failure here now I'm not gonna do this
completely irrational thing where I
could sit here and tell you Trump
obviously should have shut everything
down on February 20th when we had 15
cases Trump was very dumb and wrong to
say on febrile 8 February we have 15
cases and it'll soon be 0 that was a
dumb thing to say no president is going
to shut down a country with 15 cases I'm
not gonna sit here and tell you that
that's the logical thing that should
have been done at the time but don't
look at February 20th look at March 5th
look at March 10th okay on March 5th we
had 221 cases here in the United States
on March 5th China had 80,000 cases
proving that this could go very very big
but importantly Italy had 4,000 cases on
March 5th so on March 5th
we knew 15 cases weren't going to zero
we went to 21 we knew that a country
could have close to a hundred thousand
cases and we knew that another country
could have the disease seated and
already have 4,000 cases that's what we
knew from Italy so March 5th would not
have been a crazy time to say hey
governors all 50 of you we need to stay
at home starting now if we had done that
on March 5th
I'm not saying February 20th but if we
had done it on March 5th we would now
have done 60 days of it and we would
have had economic impacts similar to
what we've had but we would be in very
good shape right now compared to where
we are by mid March when the sporadic
stay at home orders started in some
states but not others the US had already
been seated with close to 4,000 cases of
coronavirus it was too late then to
really stop the spread it was especially
not going to happen when only some
states started stay at
home orders in the middle of March so
don't fall for the trumpets talking
point that there were no cases in
February and so it would have been crazy
to shut it down then they are right I
don't know of any president that with 15
cases would have demanded or asked 50
governors to shut things down but by
early March March 5 March 7 look at the
numbers for yourselves we had the data
that we needed to take it seriously and
Trump did not at that point in time
he'll brag he shut down travel from
China but but clearly at that point it
had gone outside of China to a
significant degree and we now have 33
million jobs lost but because of this
rolling patchwork of shutdowns in some
states and not in others we see some
states improving some worsening we still
have 2,500 deaths a day and FEMA and the
CDC believe it is possible that by June
1st we will actually be up to 3,000
deaths every single day it's been
mishandled let's be accurate in our
criticism of how it's been mishandled
but it has been dramatically mishandled
and not only are we seeing a human toll
we are also seeing an optional economic
toll we were going to have an economic
impact but we could have you know
grinned and bared it for 60 days
starting March 5th and we would be in
much better shape right now